you
[Music]
my name is Rigel I am a senior machine
learning engineer clarify and today I'm
going to be talking about something that
is near and dear to my heart and I think
it's near and dear to a lot of our
hearts which is data and it's
specifically when data can go wrong and
how it can affect your life so as the
title of my talk the unreasonable just
have the noose of bad data cool so just
a little bit of background to hopefully
motivate this talk a little bit so I
work at clarify we are an AI platform
for computer vision we got started when
our founder Matt Zieler one imagenet
back in 2013 he was using you know one
of the sort of four early people in the
kind of modern era
to use deep learning for computer vision
and he you know one like the first five
places in image net and use that
technology to found the company I think
he gave a very popular talk at this
conference a couple years ago and since
then you know things have been going
well we're over a hundred employees now
and so our products just to you know
some people aren't super clear on this
we our products basically break down
into three major categories the first is
predict and this is sort of what it
sounds like we have a suite of models
that are you know image classifier
models image detector models that you
can call our API with you know you can
send your images to us and we'll send
you back predictions and you can kind of
see that on the right here this is
literally just a screen grab from the
demo on our website so you can go and
try out all our models in real time we
have another product called create which
is sort of interesting this is our
product that allows you to create your
own image classifiers just in case none
of our models sort of fit exactly your
use case you can upload your own data
with your own tags and train your own
stuff and we'll sort of see a little bit
more about that later and we also have
search which means that we allow you to
upload your database of images to our
platform and do visual searches over
them to find things that are sort of
visually and semantically similar so so
that's cool
so at clarify I'm part of the applied
machine learning team and I find that
when
tell people this the impression that
they get is that like this is kind of
what I do right some kind of like
inception deep ResNet 1000l STM kind of
situation right you know
model to learn models and like I'm BFFs
with Jana Cohn right so that's cool this
stuff is really important obviously and
it was sort of the inception of our
company and and it is really interesting
but like the truth is for me and I think
for a lot of people that work in this
space that's not really the important
part of my day to day my day to day
looks a lot more like this right
basically looking at data you know data
used to train models data used to
evaluate models data used to tune models
and just you know sort of getting an
understanding of lots of data sets and
the way that they affect our production
systems so hopefully that gives a little
bit of background about why I want to
talk about bad data today because you
know really this is this is the thing
that that gets in my way I'd say the
most out of basically any challenge in
in our technical space so just to be a
little bit more concrete the applied
machine learning team but we're really
responsible for is machine learning in
production if there's a product that
uses machine learning which is a pretty
common situation to clarify the AML team
is on top of it we're responsible for it
you know making sure the models are up
to snuff making sure that they're
evaluated well and that they're cutting
edge day to the yard and efficient and
scalable and all these things so I like
to describe us as sort of the link
between research and product so what is
unfair because we also work really
really closely with back-end and
front-end and basically everybody else
but you know it sort of involves taking
the things that we're researching and
the things that are in academia and
making sure that we can put them into
products and that involves things like
training and evaluating and deploying
models tuning algorithms that maybe are
unsupervised things like visual search
it can even involve actually getting
data labeled and making sure that the
efficiency with which we're labeling
that data is very high and you know the
cost is low and so within this this is
sort of where I sit
training evaluating and deploying models
and this includes also working on our
custom training platform which like I
said earlier is where you can actually
train your own classifiers to fit
exactly your taxonomy and your your
domain so cool so this is what I want to
talk about today these are the questions
that I'm trying to answer and these are
also questions that I found myself
trying to answer you know in my time but
with that clarify and sort of in general
working with data so the questions are
what is bad data how do we actually
define it what's so bad about it you
know kind of why should I care if my
data is bad or not how do I expose bad
data and then hopefully the silver
lining which will be how do you make
good data bad data into good data or is
all hope lost cool so what is bad data
first of all it's important to motivate
why we actually need to talk about this
the the answer is because we need data
and I think all of us this data Sciences
here know that but I really like this
chart to motivate exactly how important
it is this is this is taken from a paper
that came out of CMU and Google called
revisiting the unreasonable
effectiveness of data in the deep
learning area era era and essentially
the question as I understood it that
they were trying to answer was how much
data is enough data like if we collect
enormous enormous amounts of data to
feed these very data hungry machine
learning algorithms we're working with
now you know at what point can we stop
at what point does a model stop getting
better and then they they had this chart
which shows that you know they they
collected this data set with 300 million
examples in it which is pretty large for
a data set and they don't really find
the point you know it just kind of keeps
going up maybe it's going up
logarithmically you can see it's like an
exponential scale at the bottom but it
you know doesn't really show signs of
stopping so so it really matters that we
have data but you know what we do with
that data so the way I hear a lot of
people talking to me about this you know
especially when they're you know maybe
they're not super familiar with the
field or maybe they're not super in
depth of it but even when they are they
talk about it
like they understand it like a blender
right you have like some data blender
and you put your data in the data
blender
and if all goes well you come out with
some kind of a delicious data smoothie
right everything's going fantastically
but till that's that's actually great so
that works a lot of the time this
analogy is is pretty much right like a
lot of the time you can really just
throw it at your algorithm and get
something that you want but it kind of
depends on like your data looking like
this right you have to make some
assumption that when your data payant
when you open your data pantry you're
going to get a lot of fruits and
vegetables and things that are gonna go
great in a data smoothie but what if
you're something like this is in your
pantry right and maybe it's not obvious
but and you know it's not to say that
this is a bad thing but you probably
don't want to put this in a blender and
get a smoothie right so that's sort of
the point here is is you have to know
what exactly you're putting in your
algorithms so the way I like to break it
down is basically with two definitions
so the first way I think about bad data
is one kind of bad data that I call
honest bad data and this is the data
that we all are very familiar with you
know this is data that's bad you know
it's bad right the models are bad or the
the labels are bad that noisy something
is wrong with the images right something
is terribly wrong with this data and
it's super obvious right off the bat on
the other hand though there's something
quite a bit more sinister that I call
deceptive bad data and this is the data
that's so bad that you think it's good
and so what does this mean so I'll have
a couple of examples here to hopefully
you know sort of illuminate that so
what's so bad about data about this well
why don't you want yourselves in these
situations well the first obvious answer
is if you have bad data you can have bad
models right you can have a situation
like this for the uninitiated right this
is the worst you can do on both of these
performance curves right you have a
precision recall with an L or the sort
of the elbow at the very bottom and a
basically a perfectly random classifier
this is not what you want but at least
if you have something like honest bad
data where the data labels are noisy you
will get a situation like this and you
will know that your data is bad and that
your model is back
but what if that's not necessarily the
case what if instead of knowing that
your data is bad in the model your
training is bad you instead have some
kind of a false confidence about your
model and this can happen more with the
deceptive bad data case in my experience
and often it happens when your test set
is not exactly the right thing to have
actually evaluate your model on it
doesn't actually reflect the real world
so just to give like an example of this
it's a little story about something that
happened to clarify we were working on a
classifier for a moderation use case
somebody who it was an e-commerce
company that we were working with and
they wanted to make sure that certain
things weren't being sold on their
website makes a lot of sense you know
this kind of thing happens all the time
people try to sell stuff that you really
shouldn't sell and so one of those
things that they wanted to find was
license plates so we thought okay like
that's great so we collected a bunch of
license plate data this is pretty
straightforward right if you've trained
image classifiers you can tell like
license plates are pretty visually
distinct you know it seems pretty pretty
straightforward to train a model to
recognize license place so we did that
and we had really great performance
numbers and you know this was one out of
many concepts that we were shipping to
them so we thought okay great well we'll
send this off and hopefully everything
goes well and then we heard back from
the customer and they said hey something
is terribly wrong your license plate
category is firing way too much like we
know there are license plates in your
date in this data but like it's firing
on like 10% of our of our total stream
or something like that like they're
definitely not this many license plates
in our data so okay fine we looked into
it and what we saw was that of course
when we were looking at the when we
started looking at what this model is
actually predicting license plate on
from their data set of course it didn't
look like this right it looked a lot
more like this obviously cars have
license plates on them this ecommerce
marketplace happens to sell cars and
this is something that we didn't take
into account when we were initially
evaluating our model we were trying to
evaluate
you know can we find license plates and
the answer is yes but in all the wrong
scenarios so this was this was a big
learning point for me so another another
way that that bad data can affect you in
sort of deceptive ways is through
machine bias and this has sort of been
in the news lately this topic that's
really starting to pick up steam and
this is can be essentially when you know
your model a model that's trained can
have unintended consequences and and
effect you know often a sensitive sort
of demographic variables in the real
world in ways that you really didn't
want to do and really didn't expect to
do so one great paper that I like to
talk about is this paper that came out a
few years ago it's called man is too
computer programmer as women is too
homemaker D biasing word embeddings and
so if you're not familiar with with word
embeddings essentially the idea is of
course you you you have a vector that
represents every word and you try to use
these vectors to create your classifiers
and encode your text with so that's
great and there's this really great
party trick you can do with them where
you can do all these great analogies so
you can subtract vectors and sort of get
these really semantically meaningful
things like they find that if you
subtract the vector for man and woman
you get a vector that's very very close
to the vector when did you get when you
subtract king and queen so this is cool
because it sort of indicates that you
know the model is encoding something
about the difference between man and
woman awesome but that can go awry and
what they found is it's not usually as
innocent as this they found also of
examples like this where the the
difference between man and woman was
also approximately the difference
between computer program and our
homemaker and obviously this is not
something we want right and this isn't
just a one-off case they managed to find
tons and tons of these analogies in sort
of the public word Tyvek model that of
course many many many NLP systems and
productions are reliant on so if this
exists in the underlying algorithm then
likely this exists and the algorithms
that were used that this was used to
make so this is the kind of thing that's
just sort of lurking just below the
surface and of course nobody when there
training we're Tyvek you know was
specifically trying to encode these
analogies but this was sort of latent in
the data and training a model to create
these analogical structures actually
managed to expose it another example of
this is something that was in New York
Times recently the the title is facial
recognition is accurate if you're a
white guy and what they essentially
found was that for a lot of public
facial recognition api's they are
they're much better as the further you
get along the sort of the scale of skin
tone that they defined towards the
lighter spectrum so this is a obviously
a terrible thing this is something that
I would hope that and I assume that
nobody intended for their classifiers to
do but because maybe is some latent bias
and they were in the data that they
train the classifier on this is exactly
the kind of thing that can happen it can
be really really really difficult to
expose cool so so far right what have we
talked about when you have honest bad
data you can get these bad models and
you know this is sort of the the classic
case of when you know your data is bad
but in a in the more sinister case you
can have false confidence in your models
performance because you're not
evaluating it the right way or even you
can have these horrible bias problems
and your models that are really hard to
expose and but effects a lots and lots
of downstream technologies cool so next
up is this question of how do you
actually expose your bad data so now
you're worried about bad data and you
have a data set but what do you do if
you want to find it all right so my
answer is essentially use tools there
are lots of really really great tools
out there for for evaluating your data
set for looking through your data set
for searching over your data set if
you're wondering where the plug is
coming this is it we have this tool a
clarify called clarify Explorer and this
is what I use all the time to be
evaluating models and evaluating data
sets and sort of looking through things
so what are some of the things you can
do with this tool and of course this is
not the only tool this is just what I am
familiar with so it's what I can talk
about
you can do visual searches of your
dataset you can display labels that have
been assigned to your images as you
uploaded them you can train models in
this platform and you can search with
those model predictions on that data set
so this is really great if you want to
do a sort of really quick continuous
feedback loop for for development of
machine learning and so I have this link
here that you will try to click and we
see alright great so I'm going to
attempt a live demo here I also have a
back up video in case I chickened out
but feeling lucky so here we go so far
so good
do not save no awesome so this is
essentially it this is the tool and what
you can see here is we have what I call
an application or what is called an
application and it basically sort of
represents a data set that you've
uploaded to our platform
and this is just a like a toy example
this is open images I think it's like I
just uploaded like twenty thousand
images from the data set just to sort of
like you know let us see on a high level
what's going on here so this is you know
some preview of some of the data like I
said you can do visual searches so if I
say wanted to find other examples of
images that look like that car I can
just hit this guy and it'll show me
things that are visually similar and
again this is within the twenty thousand
images that I uploaded to this car so
that's really awesome right that seems
really useful so what can we do here
well say that for example we want to
make a model a new classifier based on
this data that differentiates between
fruits and vegetables pretty
straightforward so let's give it a name
right let's um I know because I've done
this already that open images has a
concept for fruit in it
it is here and also one for vegetable if
I could only scroll that would be great
Oh No okay
great alright awesome there's a lot of
concepts in open images so cool so we've
got this new model two concepts fruit
and vegetable this is just things that
were pulled in from the data set and so
this is just all the data you can see
it's about 400 or so examples from each
how is this rendering oh it's doing
pretty well okay so we can train the
model this doesn't take very long great
so models trained that's awesome so
let's see how we did we can hit this and
what this will essentially do is it'll
take the data that I used to train the
model it'll split it up five ways and
I'll do five fold cross validation so
this takes a little bit longer than
training but not that long so awesome so
this is the performance of the model
I've got a little confusion matrix here
you can see we have like 70 recall total
and like almost 90 precision you know
not bad for 45 seconds of work but if I
actually cared about this model I might
want to look into exactly what's going
on here so cool so we can go back to the
data set and what we can do now is we
can use this model that we just trained
to search over the data so what I'm
doing here is I'm basically saying okay
take this model that this constant that
we've trained with this new classifier
take the fruit concept and and see you
like what is predicting a highly on
fruit so okay so this seems kind of
reasonable right
we have fruits lots lots of fruits
mostly on plants we also sort of have a
lot of these like flowers right like
here we have a flower we can actually
get predictions from our general model
here we have some flowers and things
like that
and these are being predicted pretty
highly as fruit so that's not great so
what can we do well one thing we can do
is we can try to isolate those examples
so we can also in addition to searching
with concepts that we've trained on we
can also use concepts from the general
model and we can combine these
these queries sort of like this so if I
want to search for flower now these are
things that are labeled as as fruit and
they're labeled as flower so these are
the things that are basically confusing
our model so that's awesome so these are
pretty much all flowers but if you look
at individual examples there's super
high probability fruit so we can just
take a bunch of these and we can label
them with a new label something like
fruit eggs right like fruit negatives
cool so now we go back to our model and
we have this new concept fruit negatives
so we kind of want to train these
against each other so we can flip the
switch to make it use softmax in the
final layer instead of just sigmoid on
every every single concept we can
retrain a lot of this training model is
trained and so what happens is now when
we search for fruit hopefully this looks
better
pretty embarrassing if it didn't cool so
something apparently went wrong when I
did that right this is exactly the kind
of thing gonna happen right but now I
can go back and so it maybe remove those
negatives and like see exactly what
needs to be teased apart between the
fruits and and like sort of floor in
general okay so great so that's the end
of fruits I don't want to see that again
so what a vegetable though what's going
on here so that looks different right
this is food this is not really what we
saw with fruit so what does that mean
like these are vegetables right that's
kind of good to know that exactly this
is what was in my data was sort of
vegetables on a place but does that mean
that I'm like that I want the fruit to
also be on a plate do I want a food
classifier and like trying to classify
things in a market you know and so like
you know to
me when I'm when I'm doing this this is
of course just a toy example but what
I'm doing this in general this is
exactly the kind of question I a DAB
answering because I am able to expose
the nature of the data by using by
quickly training and using these models
and sort of just seeing exactly what
they do so cool that is the demo we back
do that okay cool so what do we just see
I was able to use this tool for
understanding the training data right -
a pretty effective degree I was able to
identify failure cases pretty fast I was
able to add a new concept with new data
and retrain and you know the ideas or
instant repeat you can keep doing this
for you know it's sort of until you have
a model you want and that was you know
just a few minutes right so it's really
important I'm not saying this is the
only tool out there this is just the
again this is the one that I use so it's
really important to be able to use these
tools and leverage these things in order
to have a really really good iteration
process and expose hidden things in your
data that you didn't know about awesome
so okay the silver lining how do you
make bad data into good data or is all
hope lost so there's a few ideas you
know I think everybody in this in this
field is sort of working on this like
nobody has a perfect data situation so
there's a few ideas for how you can do
this first one is just use it like don't
worry about it so much this is very
unfortunately titled paper given the
title of my talk that's called the
unreasonable effectiveness of noisy data
and fine grained recognition and this is
from 2016 and essentially what they
found was for a lot of these tasks where
they have to do really fine grain
classification they just do a big web
scrape and they have all this noisy data
and they use it in kind of clever ways
oops and what they find is they are able
to blow the competition out of the water
so there is something to be said about
not worrying about something until it's
a problem or you know at least just
trying to use a noisy data and seeing
where you end up because it could be
that you actually are going to do fine
and there's
think about it that actually that
actually is really beneficial to your
problem another thing like we saw it
just a minute ago is I didn't do this
exact search but this was from before
explore your data so you can use noisy
data in my mind to train models and use
those models even if it's not going to
be your production model in the end to
explore your data and understand your
data and understand what happens when
you pass that data through a model so
that's really really important and then
there's this sort of concept this is
kind of the oldest trick in the book
of just using the good parts so one way
to do that is to learn to use the data
even if it's noisy even maybe the labels
are very noisy if you have a lot of
extraneous labels or something like that
sometimes you can still get really good
representations of your data out of it
so this is this is a paper from matte
sealer CEO visualized using an
understanding convolutional neural
networks right you know he's talking
about features that can be learned from
the data and this is really cool
visualization of it but yeah so if even
if the data is not exactly what you want
to train on in the end it might be
useful to get you started to get a
really really rich representation of
your input space and then you know if
you're able to then you can clean the
data to a limited degree and you know
sort of fine tune on that so does about
that trick and then the last thing I
think it's useful for is just to make
you think right kind of like we saw in
the demo maybe if you see that your data
is not what you expect it to be maybe
you you have some questions to answer
about what problem you're trying to
solve right exactly what is this model
being used for what is the domain what
is the purpose and it with when you're
thinking about that problem maybe you
can think about more questions about
like okay who-who could this possibly
affect right are there chances of this
having some kind of inherent bias may be
a machine bias problem that could really
affect people's lives is there a
possibility that there's something we
didn't consider about the data the way
we the way we collected it and so yeah
so usually the data the the purpose of
bad data in my mind is to actually give
me questions instead of answer them
so one that we talked about today so bad
data in my mind takes essentially these
two forms they can be honest that data
where you can train models on it and you
know you're going to get a terrible
model and there's deceptive bad data
where you can train a model on it and
everything seems fine until something
terrible goes wrong down the line you
can use tools to evaluate these models
you can use tools to break through that
false confidence and make sure you know
exactly what your model is doing and you
can use tools to expose inherent bias in
your data that you weren't familiar with
previously and if you're stuck with it
anyway you can just try to use it you
can use it to make representations and
you can use it to reconsider your
problem so thanks so much that's all I
have this is my email if anybody wants
to continue the conversation I would
love I would love to hear from people so
and thank you to data and account for
having these really really fantastic
opportunity
[Music]